um and then halloween is right before
the election isn't that fun right before
uh the election which
from all of the media reports should go
off without a hitch
should be very calm and peaceful
the media is literally going out every
minute going uh there's going to be
civil unrest
there's going to be uh i mean what are
we all preparing for
voting's already started it's mail-in
voting you can already vote trump's
telling people to vote twice
everybody and i tweeted today
this is so much of a bigger problem than
trump trump is a big
problem he's not doing a good job that
being
i mean that's putting it as mildly as i
can put it for you psychopaths out there
they're like
no no so many people get mad at me when
i say it
no and here's the other thing he doesn't
like the military guys you know he
doesn't like the military
i think that article in the atlantic
should have been sourced but you know he
doesn't like the military
you know he doesn't respect people that
wear uniforms for no money i don't care
what you do garbage man
uh anything he doesn't respect that he
does not like the military
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about first
responders he doesn't get it in his own
mind he doesn't get
he might not actively hate them he
doesn't get it he doesn't get it why a
guy
would wear a uniform and potentially die
for a job that pays him
70 000 a year maybe and that's not even
i mean that's like after you've been in
for a while he doesn't get that
you're you you don't get trump if you
think he's perplexed i think he's
genuinely confused
as to why anybody would do anything that
doesn't net them a lot of money
and the ability to [ __ ] models and live
in a mansion or live in a high-rise
apartment like
he doesn't get it it's just not his game
you see it's not what he's into he
doesn't
he doesn't respect like uh emt's
first response i mean it's not his thing
you think he really likes the military
by the way do you really believe
when you put your head on the pillow do
you truly believe
that donald trump understands like the
sacrifices that
service men and women make do you
believe that
you don't believe trump's a little
confused
you don't think if he looked and goes
you're making thirty six thousand 000
a year what are you doing get out of
here
you don't think he's a little perplexed
by that
he doesn't get it what does he do that's
not for him
what has he ever done in his entire life
that doesn't directly benefit him
well the presidency i love that people
go well he's president he's actually
losing money
he's not and also people there's some
people that would argue being the leader
of the free world's
a benefit some people would say that
that's a benefit
so he's not actually it's not a selfless
pursuit you see controlling a nuclear
arsenal
the world's you know most powerful
military running you know the
economy you know to the extent he wants
to or can
that's not exactly uh a step down from
where he was so
he doesn't like the military i mean it's
just what it is there's a great part in
that atlantic article this is an article
if you don't know
came out in the atlantic magazine
jeffrey goldberg who's the editor of the
atlantic
uh some of their shit's fine that they
write and some of it i don't like i
think this should have been on the
record by the way
fox news though did confirm a few
high-ranking trump administration
officials that were on board with this
uh the military does not want him in
they do not want him in so you can
continue to like and love and support
him
the military doesn't want to they want
people they want recruitment numbers up
and the recruitment numbers
don't aren't high if you're joining
military and you think you're going to
fight your friend
in the street so when trump says we're
going to send a military in everywhere
you might agree with it you might say we
need law and order but it doesn't
exactly help it doesn't drive
recruitment
numbers if you think you're going to be
deployed on on your streets fighting
nobody really signs up for that so the
military
it's just a lot of them are just not a
fan of this guy some of them are some of
them certainly are
but a lot of them aren't and they know
he's doesn't respect what they do
they know that and you know that if you
think
doesn't respect can you imagine
explaining to trump
why you joined him like i believe
that i'm making a sacrifice for other
people's freedom
his eyes would glaze over in his head
like you were speaking in alien language
by the way my eyes almost glaze over
in my head when you tell me that's why
you're joining the military
i am a little like what
i'm like and by the way i'm glad people
do it but after we know
what the leaders of this country ask
these people to do
i'm a little like really like i would
understand much more if a guy goes i
love killing
i can't kill at home i gotta kill abroad
and then i go okay he goes i like
violence that's how i
come i enjoy making someone go
bye-bye and i know that that's not
everyone in there there's a lot of
people in there that do believe in
ideals and that's great
but there's a few people in there's
certainly a few there's a couple of
people in there
that really just want to bathe
themselves in blood
and i would understand that as an
explanation almost a little more than
somebody who's like
i just want to secure our freedom and i
go okay
good for you again i don't understand it
either so stop pretending that trump
understands it
like i barely understand let's be very
honest you don't understand that
and if you did you'd be there unless you
are in the military and
and thank you for your service and
everything whatever
i do thank you for your service i mean
some of it some of it i thank you for
some of it i think we got to stop doing
i got to be honest
it's a half and half some of your
service i say yes and some of it i go we
can't do that anymore
it's a problem but i don't understand do
you understand it
of all the jobs you could get it's hard
to understand right
it's very hard to understand i'm gonna
back up trump here a little bit
it's a little difficult to understand
i'm kind of with him
if we were eating a steak on the upper
east side of manhattan and donny turned
to me and goes what the [ __ ] are they
doing
i'd go yeah i don't know donnie
yeah i don't really know it's freedom
and
it's our freedom and they he'd go thank
god someone's doing it and then we'd
have a nice little cheesecake i'm
telling you
i'm telling you stop the fantasy that
this guy is like
some a proud military historian who
loves the miller is just not what it is
i know we need a military they need to
be strong they need to kick ass
some some of my fans are in it i'm
[ __ ] happy they do it i wish they had
better civilian leadership
i wish the people in the military cared
more and i don't mean
the rank and file i mean the brass and
more so than even the brass the
politicians
those are the problems i wish they cared
more about
veterans yes and i wish we had better
veteran health care
mental health care all of that [ __ ] 100
okay but let's just analyze for example
let's just take a look at the decision
that level of selflessness of bravery uh
you know in many cases we're excluding
now the sociopath we just want to watch
things blow up
we're saying the other people that is
hard to understand
i don't i don't want to go to iraq
i don't
it's a little difficult to grasp and i
know that
and i know that we're all you know
everyone's horrified they're trump but
most guys that make millions and
millions of dollars
don't understand people that do anything
especially if it could kill them
for for not a lot of money they don't
get it
but people get people get high on
different things in life right
some people like danger some people like
risk some people like physical
physicality they want to be out moving
they want to work with their hands
some people want to sit behind a desk i
mean all those wall street [ __ ] their
risk is is financial
you know primarily like they're not
putting their bodies in danger
but they're putting you know they might
be putting uh
their family or their their financial uh
you know their entire enterprise at risk
all the time depending on the decisions
they make
and that could affect themselves their
company their employees but they don't
put their body in teacher
so it's hard to explain to guys like
that why you would do a job that might
get you
killed it's tough you know when people
become
i don't understand why anyone becomes a
cop either
i don't get it i get firemen because
it's fun because there aren't a lot of
fires
and they don't really do much and they
have these big meals in the firehouse
and the first guy i sucked off was a i
think a volunteer fireman i don't even
know
something it was after 9 11 he was
trying to do it i don't know if he ended
up doing it or not
but he had a huge dick and i always
remember his dick like
of all firemen have that dick where it's
like not
insanely long but fat like a hose you
could use
now i don't know what happened to that
person i assume he's dead
but i'm kidding of course about they're
not being fires there are fires in
los angeles all the time there's so many
fires just kind of embarrassing
but everyone's like are you donating the
firefighters it's like not really
because the fires come back every year
so we're at a certain point now where
it's like i just don't know if we're
gonna get we're just throwing good money
after bad here
it's like guys can you do a job or not
i mean you do the job and then two weeks
later there's fire's back so
i'm no expert and yet i still think
that's not really a good track record
okay people are getting evacuated
three or four or five times out of their
[ __ ] houses but i understand that job
but if somebody tells me i'm gonna be a
beat cop
i'm just gonna walk around and we need
them
we need people to do these jobs but let
me but let's be a comedian
that's a great ego who the [ __ ] on can
go explain that to someone yes i'm gonna
work for 10 years and be broke and maybe
even longer than that
on the off chance that maybe i
i figure out how to be funny and then an
even slimmer chance
that i can market that to people and
make a living doing that and it's a
brutal
process so people don't understand that
no one understands anything really
other than like oh you make money got a
big house
so if i do the job that makes me i get
the house and the money in the car i get
that
but anything that you do that doesn't
immediately net you financial results
nobody in america understands i don't
understand
it and i do one of those things i spent
a decade doing it
i was just like a weird calling it was
something i had to do and maybe that is
the military but trump doesn't
understand that he doesn't understand a
calling
he doesn't understand like higher
purpose or the idea that this is what
you should do in your life
he doesn't get that everything's a game
this is he's a casino magnet
he's playing a game and why play such a
game that could kill you
why play a game that could knock you out
and that's that's a fact and that's just
what it is
i understand you know but it would have
been nice if they sourced the article i
don't know maybe they will